Speaker 1: Something strange is going on.
And it's strange even for Donald Trump's standards.
He is now regularly posting and reposting
messages to truth social in the middle of
the night wrote Central.
Forget about the fact that he sometimes doesn't
even know what his own platform is called.
Forget about that for a second.
This really might be the end of Trump, but
I want to be very careful about prematurely
reporting the death of one's political career.
They can come back.
There were people in 2016 who said Trump has
no chance, and of course they were wrong.
Even recently, even close to the 2016 Election
Day, I thought Trump had no path to victory.
So let's be careful about declaring his political
career dead.
But Donald Trump does seem very damaged at
this point in time.
He's being kept out of the Georgia Senate
race, Herschel Walker's race in Georgia, and
he is now regularly posting nonsense to truth
social.
All night long, check out this really strange
stuff.
On Tuesday, around 10:30 a.m., Donald Trump
posted in all caps.
Remember, you can never have fair and free
elections with mail in ballots.
Never, never, never, won't and can't happen.
And then at 213 in the morning, early this
morning, Donald Trump retrofitted, adding
also in all caps.
One more.
Never.
Trump also posting at 12:15 a.m. this morning.
This election cycle reminds me so much of
2016, much more so than 2020, where I actually
did much better.
Got 12 million more votes.
Fox News and the Wall Street Journal.
The Wall Journal were terrible to me, much
like today, until I won the election.
CNN, when they actually had great ratings,
was terrific.
They covered me no matter where I went.
24 seven.
The big difference is my record best economy
and border, no inflation or wars, energy independence,
record jobs, strong military, world wide respect
and so much more.
And then dozens, just dozens of other retro,
retro things, sort of like a retweet because
Troth Central just copied Twitter.
But as you page down, it's just video posts
and retrofits and just endless, endless, endless
posting dozens and dozens and dozens of time.
He also went after Karl Rove in one of his
rants, posting, quote, Rhino Karl Rove, a
man with a losing record, the likes of which
few political operatives would be able to
get away with, including his loss to me in
2016, fight so hard and so stupidly, but is
constantly on Fox News and the once Great
Wall Street Journal explaining how things
should be done.
And he doesn't have a clue.
People can't stand him.
A clone of even more unpopular Paul Ryan,
who sadly runs Fox News now on a very bad
path.
Rove is a denier of deniers, but it's completely
misspelled.
D i and i.
E r.
Am I missing something about what Trump is
doing here?
Misspelled denier of deniers which makes him
a fool.
Watch.
So the important question.
Is whether Trump is actually weakened.
Is Trump actually weakened right now?
Well, what are the betting markets say and
what are the latest polls say?
If we start with the betting markets.
Indeed.
Ron DeSantis has as strong of a position in
the 2024 Republican primary as he has ever
had.
Donald Trump is still in a very respectable
second place.
Now the numbers need a little bit of interpretation.
If you had a situation here where Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump had never been president
and had either both or both or neither had
announced that they were running in 2024.
And you saw these numbers, you might say,
okay, I mean, it's still very early.
Neither has announced and neither has been
president.
40, 32.
Okay.
It's kind of not not hugely meaningful.
The difference is Ron DeSantis in the betting
markets is now healthily ahead of Donald Trump.
Ron DeSantis hasn't announced that he's running
for anything and Donald Trump has already
been president of the United States.
And yet you see these numbers.
That is quite interesting.
We then can look at actual polling and we're
only looking at this like every couple of
weeks.
It's it's not really a horse race yet, but
it is interesting to see that the polling
is quite split right now.
A new YouGov poll has Trump up six over DeSantis,
but notice it's only 36 to 30.
And when you look at more data, you see that
Don Junior is polling 9% in that poll.
Imagine that Mike Pence is pulling 8%, etc.,
Trump plus six.
There's another poll from Communication Concepts
which already has DeSantis plus five, 45 to
40.
And then as you read down the line, you see
that there are polls in which Donald Trump
is leading and polls in which Ron DeSantis
is leaving.
But importantly, it is so early in this thing
and Trump has already been president and Ron
DeSantis hasn't even announced that.
It is quite stunning to a degree to see Donald
Trump polling this poorly.
Trump was polling poorly at the beginning
of the 2016 Republican primary, and so we're
making no conclusions.
But his increasingly erratic behavior being
kept out of Georgia when it comes to Herschel
Walker and both the polling and betting market
data not looking particularly good, 2024 could
be a very different Republican primary and
a contested Republican primary against a former
Republican president.
That is a very different situation and quite
unique.
We're going to follow it.